one of my big takeaways from this movie
is walking away and thinking about
memories you have the good and bad but
it doesn't matter we are all a product
of our experiences so I wanted to talk
about some just some random memories
that pertain to certain things that
happen in this movie first question I
have for you is what is the worst gift
you've ever received oh gosh I get okay
probably most recently I've been dealing
with some digestive issues so I can't
eat a lot of things so someone gave me
this beautiful egg welcome bask of so
many chocolates and sweets and things
that I love and I couldn't eat it and I
just stared at it for a week before I
gave it to the 80s and I said would you
please take this and eat this
someone has to enjoy it I hate gifts I
always hate getting a gift I always hate
to have to open it up I never know one
that yes if you're expected to open it
up or not expect it I always say can I
take it home and open it up I don't know
why but getting gifts is is difficult
what about giving gifts are you giving
gifts is easy okay giving gifts is easy
but I always feel embarrassed I will say
this and I would like to say this that
not worst or best but you should know
that Robert Forester gives everyone oh
yeah on these a gift cast crew yeah
every evening gave my wife again
she got a keychain know what you all we
all got letter letter openers yeah I
just wanted to see if yours was
different than mine yeah no I think we
all got literal is there a special
meaning behind that I don't know but
it's it's one of the classiest things
I've ever with experienced in my life
I've never I've never dawn on me occur
to me to do
I mean literally everyone is there
anything on your bucket list that you
still have to do I'm pretty good about
doing the things that I want to do just
because I feel like you know in taking
care of a father who got a lung
transplant and realizing that we really
are it's just it's fleeting right our
life is fleeting and you can't take it
for granted and you have to kind of
seize the day as they say and I think
for me a lot of my stuff is you know
traveling I really like to travel and
see different people's way of life and
cultures and food and I really enjoy
those experiences but I think like I
want to learn how to tap dance and I did
I just said I want to learn how to tap
dance I started to do late in life
yeah it's harder late in life to learn
things in general especially languages
my um my father is trilingual he speaks
Ukrainian Spanish in English and I would
just like to be able to be fluent in one
of them one other language I have a hard
time speaking English so I'm hoping to
heavy go back to this career I've had
the good beginning of the first act a
good beginning of a second act and this
maybe be Guinness the third act and I
will hope to stretch it out a little bit
figure skating figure skating it's funny
when I saw you socks today I thought of
figure skating because of the sparkles
I just thought those look like figure
skating stars I'm not kidding I almost
said that you walked in yeah well
someday these socks are gonna be
underneath the pair of ice skates and
I'm gonna be dancing around I have no
doubt that you can do that anything that
you set your mind to what's something in
your life that seemed terrible at the
moment but in hindsight you appreciate
having gone through it divorce hmm yes
you the loss of something that you
thought was forever
um 2-wheel yeah that's no it's beautiful
I I agree for me probably when I there
was a few months where I didn't realize
I was having all these feelings and I
didn't realize I had anxiety and I
didn't realize it was something that was
really affecting my life and then and
just I mean just my daily life and
having that clarity realizing oh what's
going on what's happening and realizing
it's not my fault you know it's um it's
hard to go through but then you get
months down the road here down the road
and you realize oh you move on you you
learn from me and you try and just
handle things better the next time I'm
sure you have many memories from making
this movie but you know if you kind of
had one memory to put in a scrapbook
what would it be it would be the the it
would be the line that did not get into
the movie because I heard a guy say at
one time he was playing tennis and he
said to the other guy
are we playing cheating or not cheating
and and I used the line when we were
playing the Chinese checkers and it did
not get in the movie but that was my
favorite moment this movie I kept
thinking I hope that makes it I know I
think just the dynamic between all of us
it's really a beautiful experience to
work with each and everyone on this cast
and for different reasons there the
strengths they brought to it the
humility the the courage getting to work
with this one has been a dream of mine
and it finally happened and every day I
told you that and it's just it's the
experience I think there's a scene that
didn't make it in the movie that I got
to work one-on-one with Michael Shannon
who's someone I have adored for so long
and I've had one in one moments with
everyone else in the film so I was a
little sad it wasn't in there but it was
just us smoking a cigarette and talking
about life and then I was beautiful I
hope the world sees it one day you know
for me shooting in Chicago was very very
moving because that's where I started
acting basically
and being in that apartment you know
that was our parents place in the movie
just being in that part of town Hyde
Park and I always remember the sky when
we were shoes all there's always it's
always very great [ __ ] but I have so
many specific memories from it doing
that scene in the vestibule yeah where
I'm like reading you the riot act and
then you kind of break down that was
heavy
getting to the heart of the matter of a
story in those moments when you hit that
it's like it's special because it you
can relate to in your own life - there's
the correlation within this story I
think to tell a lot of people they don't
know